there are new questions this morning
about a justice department effort to
tackle chinese spying mit professor gong
chin was among those arrested under the
so-called china initiative he faced up
to 20 years in prison accused of hiding
his ties with the chinese government in
a u.s government grant application but
last month the charges were suddenly
dropped in his first tv interview
professor chin chairs our chiefs tells
our chief investigative correspondent
jim axelrod that he believes the case
was racially and politically motivated
jim good morning good morning nate
donald trump's justice department
launched the china initiative in 2018 to
tackle a top national security priority
hunting down those responsible for
china's widespread theft of hundreds of
billions of dollars a year in american
trade secrets and intellectual property
we learned the department's search for
chinese spies spread beyond business and
government targets deep into the halls
of american academia where it ensnared
at least one innocent professor
who wasn't a spy at all
we thought we had achieved the american
dream until this nightmare happened gong
chen's nightmare began in january of
2020 a u.s citizen for more than two
decades the mit professor was returning
home from china when he his wife and his
two children were stopped by federal
agents at boston's logan airport what
were you thinking as this was happening
it was very uneasy they brought my
entire family to a separate area
and we sat there for a few hours agents
questioned him and demanded he'd turn
over his cell phone and computer then he
was let go and heard nothing until a
year later i was making coffee there
around 6 30 and i saw a group of people
chen whose family was a victim of mao's
regime 50 years before
suddenly had a group of federal agents
surrounding his house and what did they
say to you they said are you gang-chan i
said yes they said don't move my wife
was in her sleep and she told me she
heard the man yield police police she
saw that she was in a dream she thought
she was dreaming yeah they were going to
take him away they put
handcuffs on me i got scared he was
locked up and released on bail a few
hours later in a criminal complaint
chen was accused of failing to disclose
information about his ongoing
affiliations with the people's republic
of china as required on a 2017 energy
department grant application at a press
conference then u.s attorney andrew ling
made plain the stakes of the case this
was not just about greed
but about loyalty to china there's no
facts in what they said
so let me just ask you for the record
have you ever
been a spy for china absolutely no
spying i'm a u.s citizen and
so the answer is just absolutely no but
the world-renowned mechanical engineer
faced up to 20 years in prison
one of more than two dozen researchers
charged under the justice department's
china initiative
most of them ethnic chinese we are here
today to say enough
is enough former doj officials tell cbs
news the prosecutions were meant to send
a message to deter the academic
community from hiding research ties that
china could exploit i felt it was an
attack on all chinese americans in
america particularly in academia mit
president rafael reif said the news of
chen's arrest came as a massive jolt i
had to say i need to know more not
because i didn't trust my colleague but
the department of justice we don't
expect them to make a mistake reif
immediately spotted their first mistake
prosecutors accused chen of personally
pocketing 19 million dollars from an mit
collaboration with a chinese university
in shenzhen i know
that that is not true because i know the
money came to mit for the research the
collaboration was even advertised on
mit's website
reif decided the school would pay chen's
legal fees he was accusing of doing
something wrong for doing his job
so i had to come to his help the justice
department denies bias in its china
initiative cases we never
investigate or prosecute based on
ethnic identity but a year after it was
filed doj's case against gong chen fell
apart documents reviewed by cbs news
revealed an energy department official
told doj in early january
they'd got it wrong he never hid
anything he did from anybody within
weeks prosecutors called chen's attorney
robert fisher to tell him they had
dismissed the indictment and his client
was a free man how often have you seen a
full and outright dismissal like this
it's very rare and what does it indicate
it indicates a major mistake was made
and yet we found doj has dropped eight
cases against ethnic chinese researchers
charged under the china initiative
president reiff says the cases have had
a chilling effect we do have a problem
with china all i'm saying is just going
to universities and look for chinese
americans and doubting their loyalty to
this nation is not the right approach
use a scalpel not a hammer absolutely
after being placed on leave chen has
returned to teaching at mit this
semester still haunted by his arrest we
try very hard to go back to normal but
also i know i will never be the same
country again
andrew lelling the u.s attorney who
questioned chen's loyalty is now in
private practice and declined our
request for an interview the justice
department also declined an interview
but after we reached out the department
told cbs news it had concluded an
internal review of the china initiative
and later today
is expected to announce changes to the
program six cases are still pending
against researchers three of whom
are american citizens changes we hope
are improvements i i would be curious to
know i know that mr chen has a piece of
paper that says the charges have been
dropped did he get an apology not only
didn't he get an apology just the
opposite one of the prosecutors involved
in the case told us he has no regrets
about the prosecution because it
achieved a policy aim of
general deterrence meaning anybody
thinking about doing something similar
will now think twice except for one
almost
collateral damage yeah exactly on the
back of an innocent man
jim thank you